welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and Ant-Man of the WASP quanamania
introduces us to Kang the Conqueror
promoted in all the movies marketing for
months now as a time traveling warlord
exiled in the quantum realm and this
video is brought to you by our good
neighbors over at State Farm spoiler
morning if you have not seen quantumania
yet I know it's opening weekend but a
lot of you have seen it and are asking
me about this question in particular how
did Kang get here well we learn exactly
who exiled this King into the quantum
realm it was the Kang Dynasty
specifically three kings backed up by a
legion of thousands of gangs who
apparently love family reunions I
explain who all these gangs are in my
post credit scene video but I think we
need to explore further what exactly
happened between our Kang and the rest
of the dynasty because while Kang hints
at what happened we don't really see
fully what went down or grasped the full
implications of it or fully understand
he who remains role in all of it so in
this video let us break down the full
history of the Kang war and for deeper
analyzes of this movie and more our new
channel the Deep dive is now live and
there you can see my live breakdown of
quantum media where I answer a ton of
questions and Friday the 24th will be my
deep dive investigation of the film's
Hidden Agenda subscribe at Deep dive NR
and the best way to support our growing
new rockstars network is to check out
our merch at nerdride.shop including our
guanamania inspired shirt the quantum
thief or something from our Deep dive
collection okay Quantum media explains
that Kang was exiled into the quantum
realm when the Kang Dynasty sabotaged
his ship stranding him there in a place
outside of time and space the
post-credits scene shows Kang variant
Pharaoh Rama touch taunting the other
saying it must really eat you up that
you're not the one who killed him and
Lion King to conqueror really did a
number on that one in particular when
Janet recalls the moment she realized
the true nature of Kang we only see the
briefest of flashes to his past war
crimes a memory of Kang in what looked
like a charred Forest like one after a
wildfire using his hand mounted beams to
vaporize several fleeing people
including women and children Janet also
sees entire planets exploding and the
blue flowing sacred timeline bursting it
happened so so fast we don't really
process the full extent of it and so
later when Kang reunites with Janet he
asks her what she saw Janet says a
Monster who thinks he's a god Tang says
when you see time the way I do you don't
get to close your eyes Janet scoffs and
you're the only one who sees Kang says I
am the only one who can see it's broken
and Janet asks and who broke it K
explains I did every version of me our
variants throughout the Multiverse play
with time like children but I saw How It
Ends I saw their chaos spreading across
realities universe is colliding endless
incursions I saw the Multiverse and it
was dying all because of them so I took
control Janet's not convinced you mean
you started a war and now you want to
wipe away any universe that's a threat
to you that's what monsters do Kane
corrects that's what conquerors do they
burn the broken world and they make a
new one Janet says you don't care about
saving anything or anyone you only want
revenge because they beat you because
you lost okay interrupts her angry now I
have lost you have no idea what I have
lost and I will burn them out of time
for what they've done to me Janet says
you'll be wiping out entire timelines
murdering trillions of people and Kang
says I wish that mattered Janet now the
scene Cuts away here and it's really
abrupt as if there was more to this
conversation that they edited down but
can
I kept turning away and there's really
no dramatic button to this
this is definitely more here which is
why I think many of us left the theater
feeling curious about what really
happened between the Kings now we
already got a couple versions of this
history from the Loki series The Kang
variant he who remains explained the
backstory of the 31st century scientist
Nathaniel Richards who met his
multiversal variants and
narcissistically got along with them for
a period until not every version of me
was so so pure of heart new worlds
meant only one thing new lands to be
conquered the peace between realities
[Music]
erupted into all out War each variant
fighting to preserve their universe and
annihilate the others this was a more
detailed version of the Dogma that Miss
minutes explained in the first episode
long ago there was a vast multiversal
War countless unique timelines
nearly resulted in the total Destruction
of well everything but of course it was
not the timekeepers who ended the war
and wove all the warring timelines into
one sacred timeline it was he remained
using Elias and the TVA infrastructure
to prune all other timelines that might
produce a king other than presumably the
timeline that led to him now much like
Hal Scott and hope and Cassie can shrink
or grow to a variety of sizes people's
car insurance comes in a variety of
sizes too like a driver with their first
hatchback could have very different
needs than a hank pin level experience
driver with his sweet vintage ride well
State Farm's years of experience in
their industry leadership make them the
best choice for your insurance needs
whatever they might be with over 19 000
agents State Farm is the good neighbor
that shows up for their customers so
whether you're re-watching quantumania
for the third time or scrubbing through
every previous Marvel trailer for hints
that Tang was there all along you'll
know State Farm is there too just me am
I the only one who's looking forward to
doing that so call or go to
statefarm.com to get a quote today Kang
the Conqueror started the multiversal
war in which this gang was paranoid that
his fellow members of the dynasty were
too childishly Reckless with the
timelines causing too many incursions
which was defined in Multiverse Madness
by Reed Richards as when one Universe
collides with another universe and too
many of these in Kang's opinion was
killing the Multiverse Too Many Kings
interacting with each other threatening
the stability of the Multiverse and so
this Kang went timeline by timeline
destroying these timelines so that they
could not collide with each other that
might be why we see him in the forest it
metaphorically represents what Forest
management is using controlled Burns so
that the trees don't have to compete for
sunlight but Kang did this in a really
dirty way like many Forest managers and
many gardeners he got his hands dirty he
burned cities destroyed planets murdered
trillions of people he did it the
old-fashioned way vaporizing person by
person out of existence until there is
nothing keeping that timeline flowing
this is what he means by burn them out
of time he did all this from the inside
out and left the scar cauterizing the
wound he erased every person including
people the kings of those timelines
loved this is probably why ramita told
the other Kang it must really eat you up
that you're not the one who killed him
this is personal so forced to defend
their home timelines their own
existences each Kang went to war
accidental incursions became intentional
provocations King the Conqueror started
the Multiverse war and he who remains
ended it now when did this all happen
well when entire timelines themselves
become the front lines of a war this
sequence of events becomes confusing but
from our frame of reference King the
Conqueror was exiled decades ago and
spent years with Janet in the quantum
realm but remember everything that
happened in the Loki series and
everything that happens from the point
of view of the Kang Dynasty happens
outside of time itself so the moment
Sylvie kills he remains in the sacred
timeline erupted all of history was
immediately reset so that the kangs were
back at War again and so the big three
of the Kang Dynasty took advantage of
that and exiled the Troublemaker among
them to a place out of time the quantum
realm now they did not kill him because
killing him would mean another conqueror
could just respawn they had to trap this
conqueror in Timeless stasis and now MCU
history exists in a way where Janet knew
a king in fact that could be why when we
saw Janet in 2018's Ant-Man the WASP
before Thanos before the Time Heist that
skewed Loki into a branch timeline that
broke everything in the events of the
Loki series and Unleashed The Gangs
Janet then never mentioned Kang and
didn't seem too worried about Scott
going back down to the quantum realm in
that movie's post-credits scene so what
changed well Loki changed everything and
now in quantumania's post-credits scene
it doesn't seem like we see a Victor
timely anywhere in that Arena which
could feed into my theory that the
second post-credit scene with Victor
timely is showing us the origins of the
TBA how he remains acquired his initial
Workforce leading to him pruning the
entire town of timely Wisconsin to build
the TBA we know today that's just my
theory but to recap the question of this
video why was Kang the Conqueror exiled
by the dynasty well it's because he
started the multiversal war to stop them
from overpopulating and killing the
Multiverse he who remains ended the
multiversal war to damn the flood into a
single stream Sylvie guilty Remains the
floodgates reopened then the dynasty
exile the Conqueror to a realm removed
from time because killing would mean
another conqueror could respawn and now
the dynasty blames their multiversal
flooding on the Avengers and thanks to
our friends at State Farm for sponsoring
this video I've been dying to say this
like a good neighbor State Farm is there
call or go to statefarm.com to get a
quote today hey another reminder to
subscribe to the Deep dive you can
support our growing Network by getting
something at nerd riot.shop like this
shirt the quantum thief or something
from the deep dive collection you can
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at
eat avos follow new rockstars subscribe
to new rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
thank you
foreign